western states are struggling as lake  mead hits historic levels leaders in  california taking new action while its  supply is also critically low new  restrictions specifically target  southern california the los angeles  mayor saying the city has now entered  phase three of conservation efforts  which means watering days will be even  more limited  we if we make the right decisions won't  have to see extreme measures now  if we don't take those measures you're  absolutely right there isn't a plan b  the first three months of the year were  the driest in state history also worth  noting california is the largest user of  the colorado river which supplies water  to much of the west including of course  nevada